okay playing dr. Crowe who is not  Carlson I thought maybe was Carlson  earlier but it's okay let's redeem  myself and not mouth such Columbo what's  up okay play normally shove g5 I can  take and put the Queen on each six nine  on each for maybe ff4 is interesting I'm  playing some exotic chess I want to play  this move just put all the pieces on the  kingside everyone's invited to the party  queenie 396 is nice  well each file occupied even more  occupied than wall street's this is a  threat oh this is so nice black can't  really defend come I can't defend  against the Queen's ACK Wow well the  game well the game I'll put that on  YouTube that will be my one youtube  highlights from this tournament you two  people hope you enjoyed that I'll see  you in the future